hi there it's day 80.
uh 10 days to go i can't say that i'm
not looking forward to when the 90 day
period will be over
uh i'm going to continue with my korean
but i won't feel any pressure to do
anything i won't be loading up uploading
videos every day
today was a bad day from a technical
point of view
i went to my korean dry cleaner picked
up a sweater we had a conversation
in korean and for some reason the video
was all messed up and so i couldn't use
it then i went to the office and had a
conversation with alex and mark
lasted about 10 12 minutes we talked
about what i'm gonna talk about now
and then for some reason um
youtube won't upload it it says file not
supported or something like that so i
don't know what's going on you're stuck
with me
what we talked about and what i'm going
to talk about is the the issue of small
talk which i've talked about before
because i had lunch today with a fellow
called keith swain who i've known for a
while who is an accomplished linguist he
speaks spanish german
ukrainian
a little bit of polish
i don't know what else portuguese maybe
i don't know french he speaks very well
and he also has an interesting business
where he teaches languages using his
methods
in starbucks coffee shops
and he's an interesting guy
so we had lunch after my hockey
and uh
he was we were comparing our learning
styles and he very much likes to
does a little bit of studying he likes
asimil very much for example and then he
likes to go off and find someone to talk
to
and so he's working on chinese now so he
goes to
um
you know uh there's a starbucks not too
far from where he lives and there's a
chinese barista and he goes there and he
likes to exchange a few pleasantries
with her gets her to tell her
tell him you know some phrases how to
say this in chinese and
and and he gets great enjoyment and i
guess
it's very it's it's motivating for him
to do it
i am probably maybe he represents the
majority i don't really
i'm not that interested in doing that
and what our discussion was today was
that
you know here i am doing you know my my
podcast which is probably too difficult
for me but i'm doing it because i paid
for the transcript so i'm pretty well
going to have to study them
uh and there's like i've done all the
simple stuff
and there's no really kind of less
difficult material that's interesting
so i'm doing this material which is not
probably helping my short-term fluency
it's not helping my short-term ability
to make small talk but it doesn't bother
me because
i'm quite convinced that
if i get enough of this in me that
eventually as the need
arises for small talk i'll be able to
handle a small talk but the small talk
is not my goal and i don't need the
reinforcement of some successful small
top to small talk to get me to the next
stage
probably though a lot of people do
so different learning styles i always
say and i haven't said this for a few
videos here you got the attitude towards
the language and towards the process and
the learning you want to do it you like
it you feel confident you got the time
that you have to spend and here during
the 90-day challenge i've been spending
more time than i normally do and you
have to develop that ability to notice
the language notice relationships notice
phrases
and and developing that ability to
notice can come from a lot of input it
can come from going over grammar time
and time again it can come from being
corrected there's so many different
things that can help you notice but you
also have to want to notice you can't
just let the language fly by you without
noticing the pronunciation without
noticing the phrases
so as long as i'm doing that it doesn't
really matter to me whether i'm engaged
in small talk or not i can do without
small talk
but
maybe for a lot of people
as soon as you've learned a few phrases
you want to go out and use them which is
fine i think it's absolutely important
that that we do whatever kind of
motivates us but i just thought it was
interesting that an
accomplished linguist like keith has a
somewhat different approach and he
thinks it would be very boring to read
about history and and politics and
things like that which interests me so
you know the main thing is to go after
things that interest you
uh
i got 10 days to go i'm going to try to
organize some kind of i call it an exit
conversation
uh at the end of the 90 days although
i i'm not interested in demonstrating
what i was able to learn in 90 days
that's not the goal of this thing the
goal of this thing is to motivate
all of us who took part in this thing to
motivate ourselves
individually ourselves and to help
motivate other people just to spend more
time because it creates momentum because
now i have some momentum in korean that
had been kind of languishing without any
real progress and now i really feel that
i've got this momentum that'll carry me
forward so that's what it's all about
not demonstrating that at the end of
three months i'm gonna be doing uh great
although i certainly did better up at
the
korean uh
dry cleaner and the lady there was told
me how much he was impressed by my
progress and stuff and i don't think she
was just being polite and and all it
does is not because i'm you know patting
myself on the back if you put in the
time you will get results
bye for now